deux personnes nous écrivent l'une des
vosges l'autre de belgique encore pour
nous commander le même micro trottoir
sur la section il s'agit je lance
d'ailleurs cessé pas téléguidée par il
s'agit de deux étudiants françois de
grave de bruxelles brussels de et claude
martin de château qui veut l'un et
l'autre obtenir un diplôme de sexologie
faisant une étude très sérieuse sur la
débauche et il voudrait faire précéder
la présentation de leur mémoire d'une
courte séquence vidéo dans l'esprit des
micro trottoirs de gérard tabio notre
licenciés etc sexualité bon tiens
j'avais pas j'avais cette stabilisation
et comme je partais précisément belgique
à la réception rugby de votre lettre
monsieur de grave je vous dédie donc ces
quelques pignons sur rue
alors claude martin des vosges et vous
même monsieur deux graves selon la
formule consacrée à vos magnétoscopes
avez vous entendu parler d'inceste et
dans quelles circonstances monsieur dans
les boissons dans les boissons on a
entendu parler d'un c est alors qu est
ce que c'est que l'inceste morceaux de
citron ou un morceau d'orange à votre
avis l'hétérosexualité qu'est ce que
c'est bon je pense que l'hétéro vient du
des terres
donc c'est trop égalitaire c'est en
voyant l'air en se droguant avec de
l'éther mais je vois que vous filmez
mais malade qu'est ce qu'ils vont dire
pourquoi six infirmières je file
domicile et jamais vous n'avez pratiques
et l'hétérosexualité homophiles qu'est
ce que ça veut dire
bon au mot et film on découvre le mot
un homme ou d'un fils aussi au bout d'un
fil ce serait coup alors ah bah non mac
et décroche un téléphone peut être des
cas donc est ce que c'est votre avis dès
qu'un maître bon ça m'apparaît ça me dit
que dit ce quinqua dit dans seulement 10
k 10 km ça veut dire quelqu'un qui dit
dans des cas mais ça veut dire dit m
donc un personnage décadent c'est à 15
10 dans un personnage car c'est rien que
10 dans 7 des cas le mot licencieux est
ce que vous connaissez
oui elle se donne un an à licencieux
autrement dit qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
licencieux c'est un lieu où il n'y a pas
de toi je pense le toit de toile au
dessus de la tête de la personne bon et
alayli
avec ce bon il ya les rideaux bon qui
empêche justement dans le temps mais
c'est ça pour les moustiques
on m'a dit vous m'avez dit que vous ne
dormez pas avec un licencieuses oui je
n'ai pas de licence yeux réalisme ancien
trouvez vous normal monsieur qu'une
femme fasse le trottoir non pas du tout
du moins pour le pavé enfin là disons
qu'elle peut le ballet il parle parle de
construire quoi parle pas vu en faire
quoi qu'est ce qui vous fait dire que
c'est pas normal parce qu'il ya des
travaux qui doivent est resté bien dans
le domaine des hommes c'est plus un
homme de faire le trottoir cas une femme
sort pour le pavé disons avez vous
entendu parler madame de déviation
sexuelle
oui c'est à dire qu'il ya 40 heures de
cours dit mais je connais des déviations
mais pas eu des villes qui s'appelle
sexuelle qui s'appelle comment sexuelle
qu'est ce qui vous fait dire ça parce
qu'on dit depuis très longtemps et j'ai
déjà vu beaucoup de déviation partout
mais
une ville actuelle c'est différent
voyez-vous ce qu'on appelle un adultère
c'est qu'un enfant quand les jeunes
après s'adressant quand on grandit on
dit que rita d'été regardez-vous par
exemple avec la barbe sample du ter je
suis adulte hermes cc vous qu'est ce qui
vous fait dire ça
qu'est ce que c'est qu'un adulte un mois
c'est ça quand on grandit on devient de
terre autrement dit comme on dit d'abord
fait d'adultère voyez vous la différence
entre un ballet bleu et un valet rose
par exemple non moi je vois pas de
différence c'est le même qui soir aux
puissants bleus qui soit russel mâle
c'est le même il faut tout ça ménages
principal c'est que je sais faire le
ménage
si je vous dis ça donne ça d'aubin sa
double ce peut être sa douce à dos aux
dépens la grandeur du sceau du show du
seau d'eau us au dos pas du sodome plus
tôt dudus aux dom se nomme alors jeune
homme qu'est ce que c'est c'est un saut
en métal donc qui est prévu justement
généralement pour être employés par un
homme à part par une femme et un enfant
mais si je vous parle de ça dos alors ça
dépend pas ce que ça donne ça peut être
ça c'est peut être ça ça dépend la cua
la quantité la quantité de quoi tout le
rapport à quoi la grandeur du sou et
surtout quoi sous-hommes ils le tuent
sodome à la maison ça c'est un enquêteur
sadique dans ces deux géants fabio bien
nous terminons par anti coup